[Music]
on this sunday night state of emergency
newfoundland battles its largest blaze
in 60 years as wildfires rage from coast
to coast to coast the situation has
escalated and it is an evolving
situation healthcare closed from
emergency departments to labor and
delivery units more canadian hospitals
shut the door pulling the plug on pride
there were people crying there were
people devastated frustration and
confusion after the montreal pride
parade is cancelled at the last minute
plus
surfs up
man's best friend is making waves at the
world surfing championship
global national with bara nasser
reporting tonight jeff semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us one week into august and the summer
weather is taking a dangerous turn with
hot dry conditions fueling wildfires
across this country blazes are burning
out of control in southern bc yukon in
the northwest territories northern
manitoba and newfoundland and labrador
the premier of canada's easternmost
province says they're battling its worst
wildfire since
1961.
that entire province is now under a fire
ban with a number of communities in
central newfoundland under a state of
emergency abigail beeman has our top
story tonight
a frightening scene in parts of central
newfoundland with three out of control
fires
no evacuations yet but the province
wants people to be ready to move with
the wind change we're afraid that there
will be significant smoke
impact on grant falls winds or bishop
falls in the surrounding area as a
result last night
i asked minister hogan to declare a
state of emergency i buttered umpteen
under slices of bread to make sandwiches
for the firefighters at that time
so it's not frightening to us
dealing with a smoky sky at her house in
gander about 40 kilometers from flames
this fire brings back memories for linda
west clark of the last major fire crisis
in 1961.
she's been on facebook offering up her
driveway cabin and motor home to people
who need help gander did a lot during
9 11.
like that's us we just
like to take care of people the defense
minister and emergency preparedness
minister tweeted the canadian armed
forces will be sent in to help plan and
coordinate air transportation and
large-scale evacuations if needed as of
sunday afternoon details were still
being worked out but the army plans to
be there until at least the 20th
certainly over the last you know 24-48
hours the situation has escalated and it
is an evolving situation the canadian
red cross is helping people stranded on
a highway closed due to fire and smoke
and is now setting up a shelter further
west there's a lot of work that's
happening now around the pre-planning
and planning in the eventuality that
there is an evacuation order
on the other side of the country people
in bc's interior have been dealing with
evacuations for days
547 properties in olala under order to
leave more than a thousand on alert
there's a little plume of smoke there is
that at our place or is it further along
i mean again it's very difficult to test
to look a distance
saturday night was quiet as temperatures
fell but the danger isn't over we expect
some challenges today quite frankly
we're going to have a change in the
winds that we haven't seen for a bit of
time now with people on both sides of
the country anxious to have life
returned to normal safely abigail beeman
global news ottawa
and for more on those wildfire
conditions and if the forecast offers
any relief in sight let's bring in
meteorologist yvonne shell so yvonne
what can we expect
jeff no significant precipitation in the
forecast but we are tracking a slight
chance for some showers and even the
risk of a thunderstorm for areas near
gander and st john's overnight tonight
dries out once again tomorrow
temperatures will be into the low 20s a
concern across the region smoke and poor
air quality continue and we've got winds
that'll be fanning the flames across the
region southwesterly sustained at 30 but
gusts of up to 50 and they'll shift to a
westerly wind through the day tomorrow
but still seeing gusts of up to 40
kilometers per hour on wednesday areas
near st john's could be tracking some
rainfall gander could see a few isolated
showers and then it rebounds and dries
out for thursday friday with
temperatures back into the low 20s as we
shift to the fire danger rating we can
see across the region high from most
areas very high to extreme though that's
we'll be keeping a close eye on in areas
along the west 4 bc also over 50 active
wildfires across the region we're
sitting at high to extreme for the fire
danger rating temperatures are soaring
though into the low 30s for the southern
interior we may see a brief break in
terms of the temperatures on wednesday
but it still remains very hot and dry
towards the end of the week jeff
all right thanks yvonne
and turning now to concerns about
canadian hospitals which are struggling
to cope with staffing shortages growing
wait times and in some cases units
closing altogether marnie blunt reports
on a system under stress and growing
fears for the fall
hospitals pushed to the brink and staff
stretched thin pressure is mounting on
health care systems coast to coast to
coast we are seeing
rural ers and facilities closing because
of lack of
nursing staff wait times are going up
almost on a weekly basis impacting both
staff and patients alike i talked to a
nurse the other day who said to me i
spend my entire shift apologizing to my
patients patients like abigail
shellenberg who waited in a winnipeg
emergency room for 19 hours for an
injured ankle after waiting 10 hours in
the waiting room and dying in a personal
room
i started to feel like i was being
forgotten just one experience in a
health care system struggling to keep up
in rural manitoba staffing shortages are
forcing emergency rooms to decrease
hours or in some cases close altogether
a similar scenario in several parts of
british columbia including the west
kootenays in new denver the small
villages er operating hours have been
reduced indefinitely you need to get
back to a bit more
community based
management
to oversee these
these troubles that we have in alberta
physician shortages forced the fort
saskatchewan hospital to close its
obstetrics unit for at least two weeks
that means pregnant patients will need
to drive to another hospital about half
an hour away the problem is also
plaguing facilities in major canadian
cities in ottawa montford hospital
closed its emergency department
overnight this weekend amid what it
calls an unprecedented shortage of
nurses experts worry the situation could
deteriorate even more this fall with
another looming wave of covet 19.
traditionally that's also when flu
season
kind of starts around late october uh
november sort of time framing that that
has historically had uh impact on our
acute care facilities as well a reason
why carr says we need to proceed with
caution to avoid an unwelcome added
stress on a health care system already
pushed to the brink marnie blount global
news winnipeg
a day that was meant to mark a
celebration in downtown montreal ended
in chaos and confusion just hours before
tens of thousands of people were
expected to gather for the city's first
pride parade since 2019 the event was
abruptly canceled leaving many demanding
answers including the mayor dan spector
has that story
on sunday downtown montreal was supposed
to be full of color love and joy instead
there was confusion anger disappointment
there were people crying there were
people devastated montreal's pride
festival was set to culminate with its
annual parade the past two canceled due
to covet 19. tens of thousands of people
were expected to take over rene levesque
boulevard at 1pm but just after 9am
montreal pride announced online the
event was cancelled due to a lack of
personnel to ensure security we came
from paris for the parade i'm speechless
and baffled matthew velosoquitero says
his afro pride group spent countless
hours and tens of thousands of dollars
handcrafting costumes and creating a
float for the parade we have people
coming down from ottawa from toronto
we're talking about almost 2 000 people
that are supposed to be parading behind
a truck people are showing up last
minute
and we have to announce the bad news and
it's really sad this group included
refugees from countries where
homosexuality is illegal hoping to
experience their first ever pride parade
this one's being canceled it's like
it's difficult for them also taken aback
by the news montreal mayor valerie plant
i was shocked this morning the decision
was made without even trying to find a
solution maybe even talking to us
because that's what we do we
troubleshoot things we sincerely
sincerely apologize montreal pride
director simon gamash tells global news
he learned when he woke up his
organization did not have enough people
to safely run the parade and the
cancellation is his team's fault we have
to close streets and all of that to
assure the safety and the safety of all
participants and unfortunately we we
just don't have a resources to do that
many we spoke to didn't buy it they know
before for sure so i don't trust him you
cannot tell me you didn't know this
prior
by afternoon hundreds of devoted
attendees arranged their own
unsanctioned parades down saint
catherine street bringing lots of smiles
but organizers will be entering a tough
week of questions and damage control dan
specter global news montreal
israel and palestinian militants have
just agreed to a ceasefire after egypt
brokered successful peace talks
the truce begins at 11 30 tonight and
ends three days of deadly violence after
israel launched air strikes on friday
citing an imminent threat from the
islamic jihad movement at least 43
palestinians have been killed including
children and two of the militant groups
senior commanders hundreds of rockets
were fired towards israel in response it
marks the most serious flare-up between
israel and gaza since an 11-day conflict
in may of last year
the u.s senate has just passed a
sweeping 430 billion dollar bill
designed to counter climate change raise
corporate taxes and tackle health care
costs all despite being opposed by every
single republican
the bill salvages a key part of
president joe biden's domestic agenda
ahead of upcoming midterms the measures
aim to lower the cost of prescription
drugs and tighten enforcement on
corporate taxes and it will also include
the largest ever federal effort on
climate change injecting nearly 400
billion dollars into green energy
programs the bill now heads to the house
of representatives where it's expected
to pass in a vote on friday
the global fight against climate change
suffered a serious setback this past
week after china announced it was
halting its cooperation with the united
states the move follows u.s house
speaker nancy pelosi's visit to taiwan
which sparked anger and a flurry of
chinese military exercises those drills
in and around the taiwan strait were
supposed to end today but the chinese
government just announced another round
jennifer johnson has more on the souring
relations between superpowers
china is escalating its threats against
taiwan announcing a new round of
military drills expected to continue
until at least mid-august the white
house is urging peace as tensions rise
we'll keep our channels of communication
with china open with the intent of
avoiding escalation due to
misunderstanding concerns are rising
that china's increasing aggression
toward taiwan may lead to an all-out
invasion taiwan's leaders say the threat
has been there for decades but they are
fortifying their defenses if you have a
kid being bullied at school you don't
say you don't go to school
you try to find a way to deal with the
bully
and that's exactly what taiwan is doing
china's show of force is strongest in
more than 25 years came in the wake of
house speaker nancy pelosi's visit to
the self-ruled island u.s leaders call
china's fury an overreaction what
president xi decided to do was
manufacture a crisis
over pelosi's visit he's seeking an
unprecedented
third term as leader of china and this
is saber
rattling and you know chess thumping
china has also called off planned talks
with the u.s on a range of defense
matters international crime and even
climate change issues
on thursday the white house summoned
china's ambassador for a formal rebuke
and lawmakers say they won't back down
we are going to stand by our friends our
partners and our allies and clearly
taiwan is one of those being provocative
is not us
it's the beijing government but nothing
is stopping beijing from ordering a new
round of drills in the seas and circling
taiwan an island china sees as its own
chinese officials promise these
exercises will become a regular thing as
taiwan and the u.s urge china to stand
down
jennifer johnson global news washington
coming up adopt a grandparent the online
campaign supporting the elderly in
ukraine
[Music]
six more ships filled with badly needed
grain and sunflower oil left ukraine's
ports today the latest sign that a deal
struck with moscow to allow food exports
safe passage appears to be holding
millions of tons of grain have been
stuck in ukraine since russia's invasion
but moscow has now even allowed an
international commercial ship to arrive
in ukraine's waters the first since the
war began back in february though
analysts also warned that russia is now
moving troops and equipment towards some
of those southern port cities to stave
off a ukrainian counter-offensive
while many ukrainian civilians have fled
their homes some can't escape including
the elderly and those living with
disabilities many confined to their
homes are now left starving and alone
crystal commansing reports on a unique
program designed to help ukraine's most
vulnerable
sitting in her wheelchair svetlana
savchenko smiles warmly it's been a long
night she explains four rockets hit
nearby
and she hasn't slept
my home that is hardcover region but
there is no one
her cat busia her only companion her
husband and son died years ago twice a
month the volunteer from harkief hub
swings by and drops off a small plastic
bag with a few items
there's not much inside yet she's
grateful
her parting words lead to tears
take care of your mothers if you have
one
mothers are your guardian angels elderly
people are extremely vulnerable in this
war especially in areas under heavy
shelling like kharkiv the world bank
estimates the number of ukrainians
living below the national poverty line
could reach 70 percent this year it was
18 percent in 2021
every week volunteers deliver an average
of 1500 small parcels some drivers have
had their cars struck with shrapnel
still they get behind the wheel
local businesses are supporting the
effort along with unicef but the
coordinator of the harkief hub says
there are too many elderly and disabled
residents suffering there are so many
stories that can hurt you
this hard
worm
this terrible thing and there are many
terrible scenes to extend their reach
the volunteers launched rescue me
sponsors can read different profiles and
pick someone to rescue ensuring they'll
receive food and medicine
[Music]
many of the people receiving these
packages just aren't able to get out
this particular apartment is five floors
and the woman lives at the very top it
is hot
and she's been inside for months
of course it's important we want to eat
every day
ukraine does provide financial
assistance to elderly and disabled
people but it's not much those with
moderate disabilities for example
receive roughly twenty five hundred
grievna per month that's less than
ninety canadian dollars
which is desirable to help now for eight
people this bag must be divided survival
for many in ukraine extends far beyond
the front lines
crystal gomanson global news jar keith
still ahead virtually painless doctors
are using vr to manage patience anxiety
and comfort
welcome back virtual reality is often
thought as something used by gamers but
canadian physicians and surgeons are now
turning to the technology as an
alternative to narcotics as a means of
treating pain and anxiety jamie morocco
reports on efforts to make vr in
medicine a reality
and we've got a tour of victoria falls
today which is going to be lovely
scenery it's a trip without any travel
it is one of the biggest rivers in
africa or any drugs instead of narcotics
plastic surgeon dr ryan austin offers a
virtual reality headset to patients
undergoing minor surgeries it gives them
the chance to disconnect from that
visual or auditory stimulus so that they
can have a much more pleasant experience
overall it's that distraction some
experts say that dull's anxiety and
possibly even pain
dr james clarkson has used vr in his
practice since 2006. when we studied it
we found it's those patients about 30
percent of them that have an anxiety
disorder that give us the highest
reduction in anxiety research new and
ongoing also indicates exposure to
augmented reality may reduce acute and
chronic pain for some patients but the
technology is new and there's no clear
consensus whether the effect produced is
physiological or psychological experts
at the university of calgary are trying
to determine how vr stacks up against
pharmaceuticals and cancer patients
trying to manage their pain if we can
you know show that it is just as
effective or even you know similarly
effective to medications then it could
be approved last summer health canada
approved vr software for use in
radiology and a couple of months later
the u.s fda gave the green light to its
first ever vr device used to help with
chronic pain
austin has only had this equipment for a
couple of months and while he says there
are advancements to be made it's a
viable alternative to expensive and
potentially risky sedation the patient
benefits i think that the surgeon
benefits i think that the entire medical
team benefits and as well the system
benefits by not having to take that
patient to the operating room technology
that could reduce wait lists and patient
discomfort jamie morocco global news
toronto
next walking the walk canadian race
walker evan dunphy's record-setting
performance at the commonwealth games
[Music]
he will be coming to world champion the
ten thousand meter champion for canada
in the wars is evan dunphy
another gold medal for team canada at
the commonwealth games in birmingham
england as evan dunphy sees his first
place in the men's 10 kilometer race
walk the 31 year old from british
columbia also smashed his own canadian
record canada now has 26 gold medals
with 91 overall those games wrap up
tomorrow
well any pet owner can tell you the dogs
are great swimmers they call it the
doggy paddle for a reason but a group of
canines in california are taking their
aquatic skills to new heights
dozens of dogs competed in the world dog
surfing championships yes you heard that
right they competed in categories
according to their size as well as
tandem events
dogs are judged on multiple factors
including length of ride technique
confidence and wave size
i can't even explain his passion for it
and how much he enjoys it he has such a
good time people just love it
and we just like to keep it positive
have a good time make people happy
and we just really have a great time oh
it's it's an awesome bonding experience
she was found in the parking garage so
she was scared of a lot of stuff as a
puppy
and we just started going to the beach
she
jumped on one of the surfboards and i
was like yeah let's give it a try
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm jeff semple tonight's
your canada is the halifax town clock a
federal heritage site thanks for
watching have a great night
[Music]